Salut ! Aujourd'hui on est jeudi.
Le jeudi c'est le jour de "je fais ce que je veux".
Et on a décidé ensemble de faire une FAQ Snapchat.
Vous me l'avez demandé et bien je le fais !
Alors...
Comment ça se passe...?
Du plus ancien au plus récent...
J'ai l'impression qu' il y en a que je peux plus déjà lire.
Peut-être que c'est dans les réglages, vous aviez mal fait.
Parce que j'en ai ouvert aucun.
Il y en a que je ne peux plus ouvrir.
Bon, écoute...
On verra bien.
Mais... mais je crois que j'en ai perdu plein plein plein là.
Bah désolé pour ceux sur lesquels ça bug.
Je pense que c'est dans les réglages que vous avez envoyé que ça pouvait pas durer autant de temps.
J'en sais rien en fait
Mais tous ceux qui sont déjà en blanc, je les ai pas ouvert.
Et je peux pas les lire !
Alors au moins, j'ouvre ceux que je peux lire.
C'est beaucoup là déjà ! Han la vache...!
Si toutes les questions sont aussi longues on s'en sortira jamais.
"En clair : Mettre tes connaissances et techniques au service des gens dans le besoin".
Par rapport à la mémoire... d’accord, ok.
Euh... écoute, je crois que je le fais déjà.
C'est un peu... c'est un peu cette chaîne elle fait déjà ça quoi.
J'ai pas de projet clairement définit pour faire ça plus que ça, mais...
au moins, j’essaye de partager
soit mes connaissances, soit ce que j'utilise moi
avec vous par la chaîne YouTube.
Après il y a juste à le transmettre aux bonnes personnes si vous voulez le transmettre
Maitrises-tu le magnétisme voir l'hypnose ? Est-ce que tu t'en sert ?
Le magnétisme c'est pour moi, ça fait partie des choses que je range du côté des croyances.
Donc on y croit ou pas, ça fonctionne ou pas.
J'ai mes croyances, vous avez les autres...
Mais euh...il n'y a pas de fondement scientifique, alors que l'hypnose oui !
Ok pour Emi.
Alors du coup les autres...et ouais c'est ça, les autres je ne peux pas les ouvrir !
Bah je suis désolé, dégou... je suis dégouté, je rate plein de vos questions du coup.
Je sais pas pourquoi, comment...oh la vache !
Mais oui y'a trop de trucs !
"Salut Fabien, je voulais te dire que j'adore ce que tu fais ! Pour la FAQ: Quelles études as-tu faites et comment es-tu devenu mentaliste ?
J'ai fais des études qui n'ont rien à voir avec le mentalisme, parce que j'ai fais un bac Scientifique.
Après j'ai fais plutôt des formations.
Mes études...mes études sont plus des formations en fait que le parcours classique.
Comment je suis devenu mentaliste ?
J'avais déjà répondu un peu à cette question, le mentaliste pour moi c'est un mot fourre-tout.
Chacun à sa propre définition.
Mais mon parcours personnel, ça a été d'avoir une très très bonne mémoire en fait, dès le départ.
On s'en aient aperçu, lors d'un test de QI quand j'étais petit,
parce qu'il y avait un test sur le fait de mémoriser des trucs, bref, on s'est éclaté !
Ensuite, j'ai découvert la magie dans un livre de magie de Robert Veno qui s’appelle "Cours magica".
Il y avait toute une partie sur le mentalisme qui m'a beaucoup interpellé.
Et après, je me suis ouvert à la lecture de plein de bouquins,
qu'était sur la mémoire, sur le comportemental, sur les choses comme ça.
Et c'est tout ce fourre-tout qui a fait qu'aujourd'hui, je suis là !
Continuons avec Marie !
Pourquoi j'entends pas ta question Marie ?
Marie, Marie je n'entends pas la question, je ne sais pas ce qui se passe !
La FAQ Snapchat la moins organisée de la planète !
Colas ! Pour cette image, sache que le jour,
où il faudra que je te fasse monter dans un vaisseau cosmique de la vierge Marie
Je ne te prendrais pas !
*Claquement de doigts*
Manu : *Relis la question à l'écran*
OUI, c'est pour ça que je me fais des amis sur YouTube !
Ah le dictionnaire de l'impossible, mortel, il est trop bien ce bouquin.
T'as eu raison de l'acheter, j'en parlais dans une des premières vidéos des jeudi, du dictionnaire de l'impossible !
*Relis la phrase du snap à l'écran*
Et ben non, justement, effectivement je ne vois pas les snaps d'hier.
Je sais pas pourquoi, je sais pas comment ça se fait.
Le dictionnaire de l'impossible, je vous le met dans le descriptif !
*Lis la question du snap à l'écran*
Je passerai à Nantes pour roader le nouveau spectacle, donc en début 2017, je crois.
Tu avais le dictionnaire de l'impossible, c'est un super bouquin à lire.
Il est hyper intéressant,  je vous le mettrai dans les liens...dans le descriptif !
*Lis la question à l'écran*
Question répondue !
*Lis le snap*
Ahhhhh...ça c'est une belle question !
Quels sont mes principaux passe-temps ?
J'en ai plein !
A la base, je joue beaucoup aux jeux vidéos, sauf que j'y joue plus du tout depuis une bonne dizaine d'années,
parce que j'ai pas le temps et je suis vraiment addict aux jeux vidéos, c'est à dire, si je commence à jouer,
je vais jouer 5-6-7h d'affilé, assez rapidement donc je joue plus tellement...
J'aime beaucoup le parachutisme, mais j'ai pas trop le temps d'en faire souvent...
Je cours aussi...Oui, je cours...cette silhouette élancée ne vient pas de nul part
Mon vrai loisir principal c'est d'apprendre.
Mais c'est vrai hein !
Je lis beaucoup, je cherche beaucoup de choses sur internet.
J'aime bien comprendre les choses en fait.
Ouais, d'une manière générale c'est ça quoi.
Fabien ! Et bah je te répondrais correct !
Micros pression, alors les micros pressions ce sont de petites bières, comme ça, de petites pressions
et euh...et donc euh...et donc j'ai pas de vannes là-dessus.
*Lis le snap*
Une autre vidéo avec Pierre Croce, oui si on a une idée, pourquoi pas.
S'il a envie aussi, évidemment.
Après les 366 vidéos, c'est une question qui revient souvent.
Est ce que je vais continuer ou pas ?
En fait, au départ, je me suis pas projeter sur ce que j'allais faire après puisque je ne connaissais rien aux vidéos, rien à YouTube.
J'ai lancé ça le 1er janvier, comme ça pour voir et je me prends au jeu...grâce à vous !
Et ce projet là est tellement dense en fait, rajouter au reste de ma vie, au reste de mon travail sur scène.
Que déjà, je veux le mener à bien.
Déjà, que j'aille jusqu'au 31 en faisant une vidéo par jour,
ça sera déjà énorme pour moi qui connaissais rien à tout ça avant.
Évidemment, je ne me vois pas tout arrêter, maintenant du jour au lendemain.
Ça serait stupide et puis j'ai pas envie de ça en fait, j'ai envie de continuer.
Mais sous quel forme? Quel rythme? Quoi? Comment?
Je sais pas.
Je sais une chose, c'est que je ressortirai pas une vidéo le 1er janvier.
Merci beaucoup, ça fais très plaisir !
*Lis le snap*
Mais c'est bien dégueulasse ça !
Est ce que j'ai mérité qu'on m'envoie ça dans ma FAQ ?
Il est quel heure là ? Il est 12h30
Je vais manger, enfin j'allais manger, enfin je vais plus manger.
Plus jamais.
Merci beaucoup, pourquoi ?
*Lis le snap*
Question déjà traité.
Célia: Alors, qu'est ce qui ta incité à devenir mentaliste et quel était ton métier avant ?
*Rires*          *Clap*
J'avais pas mis le son de l'ordinateur.
Eh, je vous jure on va y arriver, je suis désolé Célia, je suis désolé.
*Lis le snap*
C'est quoi ? C'est ton ventre ça !
Ou alors c'est un biceps, peut-être de côté
Oui, je fais du sport, donc je cours depuis longtemps, j'aime bien ça, c'est vraiment un truc qui me fais du bien à la tête.
Et je me suis inscrit dans une salle de sport, il y a 3 semaines !
Donc c'est très récent, je vais à la salle...et ouais !
Je vais à la salle, Tibo Inshape n’a qu'à bien se tenir
Moi aussi je suis sec et gros Thibault, fais attention à toi !
*Lis le snap*
Beh...ça me fais plaisir.
Ah oui c'est tout. *Rires*
Fait très attention, parce que j'ai un pote qu'envoie: #Jesuisuntaillecrayon
Méfies-toi !
*Lis le snap*
Heeermiiiine...Hermine, Hermine, Hermine, je te connais Hermine, on s'est rencontré à Mulhouse !
Euh, au spectacle !
Hermine, toutes les questions je les aient déjà traités sauf pourquoi au théâtre.
Et ça c'est cool comme question.
Mon vrai choix, c'est d'être aller sur scène dans un théâtre, donc ça m'a toujours attiré la scène,
j'ai eu un groupe de musique d'ailleurs il y a très longtemps.
J'ai mis une photo là-dessus sur Instagram, hier soir d'ailleurs, c'est drôle.
Une photo qu'on a retrouvé, j'ai 16 ans dessus.
Donc ma vraie envie professionnelle c'était de divertir les gens.
Donc d'aller sur scène, en tant que comédien, de divertir les gens.
Et euh...et moi ma passion à la base c'est le mentalisme, d'où le fait de faire du mentalisme sur scène.
J'espère que ça répond à ta question.
*Lis le snap* Bah merci beaucoup ! Merci, je t'adore aussi.
Pourrais tu faire une vidéo, comment ne pas avoir des blanc dans une conversation ?
C'est marrant, ça fais pleins de fois que vous me demandez ça dans les commentaires des vidéos !
Sur comment ne pas avoir les blanc dans une conversation
Je...Il faut que je trouve un angle, mais on peut faire une astuce, un mercredi là-dessus ou...
peut-être même un master-class, c'est plus sur la conversation dans la globalité,
parce que j'ai l'impression que vous avez des peurs des blanc en fait.
C'est euh...Je vais me pencher là-dessus, t'es pas le premier à en parler en fait Rayan.
Raphi: Pourquoi t'a préféré t'orienter vers le mentalisme et pas la magie, comme la magie des cartes ou la magie des pièces ?
Merci beaucoup pour cette question, la première question vidéo qui fonctionne.
Alors pourquoi vers le mentalisme ? C'est vrai que j'ai découvert le mot mentalisme via la magie.
C'est ce que je disais tout à l'heure, dans le libre de Robert Veno.
Euh du coup, je fais de la magie hein, je fais des cartes, je fais des pièces, je fais pas mal de choses.
J'ai même eu quelques prix dans la magie, en 2007 j'avais eu le Cannes d'or.
J'avais eu un prix aussi pour les mendrake d'or, ça c'était dans la magie aussi.
Et après, c'est qu'une question de goût en fait, tu fais ce qui te plaît le plus dans la vie
C'est pour ça qu'il y en à qui deviennent plus dans la numismagie, la magie des pièces, d'autres dans la magie des cartes, voilà !
Réponse pas très clair hein quand même.
Ahhh !
Ah, c'est pas bête !
En fait, l'idée c'est que t'aimerais voir le tour que j'explique le dimanche, t'aimerais le voir en action.
Je crois que c'est ça que tu veux...
Comme le dimanche, je vous explique un tour ou de magie ou de mentalisme.
Vous aimeriez le voir en action sur quelqu'un qui le connaît pas, dans une vidéo.
C'est possible, je peux faire ça
Je peux faire ça, en plus peut être que ça...peut être que ça réglera un soucis que j'ai dans les tours du dimanche.
Le tour du dimanche souvent, je vous le fais voir comment ça fonctionne, c'est pour l'explication.
C'est pas pour vous bluffer vous, c'est pas ça la promesse.
Et souvent, vous me dites: "Eh grillé mec, ça a pas marché sur moi" *Rires*
Alors que c'est pas le but, le but c'est que je vous l'explique à chaque fois.
Donc, forcément c'est pas des choses qui sont adaptables, forcément en caméra quoi.
Donc, ça pourrait être intéressant.
Bon écoutez, vous me le dites dans le commentaire si vous voulez que je mette en application,
une fois dans la semaine, le tour que j'explique le dimanche, on peut faire ça.
Olala, ça va trop vite Astrid.
J'ai pas eu le temps de tout lire, je vois des pouces en l'air.
Je vois des pouces en l'air, donc ça...Pouce d'arrosoir, pouce de calendrier, pouce de...d'une orbe.
Pouce de café, pouce de...téléphone, pouce de carte de France, pouce de perceuse.
*Rires*
Mais non...Ah ça doit être ton petit garçon ça !
À Nantes, vous êtes trop influençable, mais c'est bien, faites des pouces Astrid.
Astrid, d'ailleurs que vous avez vu dans une vidéo, il y a pas longtemps, je vous la met en...je vous la met en lien.
Ah déjà, c'est un bon pseudo ça, FionFion.
Mes dons de mentalisme, me disent qu'on va se marrer FionFion !
*Lis le snap*
Voilà...tout à fait pertinent pour cette FAQ !
FionFion: Coucou, je viens de voir qu'il me reste tout juste 2 minutes pour poser ma question.
Comme j'ai vu un joli labrador sur un de tes snaps, j'aurais voulu savoir:
Si tu devais être un animal, lequel ça serait et pourquoi? Merci
Si je devais être un animal, mais je veux être un chat !
Évidemment que je veux être un chat, je veux dominer le monde.
D'une manière générale, être un chat permet de dominer le monde en dormant 20h par jour.
Je veux être un chat !
Est ce que je compte faire une vidéo sur l'hypnose ? Oui surement durant l'année, j'en ferais une.
Je pense, c'est pas programmé, mais j'en ferais surement une.
Mais si c'est dur, mais bien sûre que c'est dur de faire une vidéo par jour pendant 1 an !
Je n'avais pas du tout, pris l'ampleur du projet.
C'est dur, mais c'est vraiment super cool par contre.
Mais...mais dis donc, tu fais peur avec ce filtre là !
Team Iron Man, évidemment !
C'est pas du tout inutile.
*Lis le snap*
Eheh, on veut voir ça et on veut des preuves !
Faut que tu me mettes ça aussi sur Facebook en me tagguant,
pour qu'on puisse avoir la preuve que y'a ton nom sur les bras. Tout vendredi.
Quelle est ma date d'anniversaire ? Ah c'est vrai qu'on la trouve pas trop parce que je l'ai même pas mise sur Facebook.
Parce que ça m'énervait en fait, d'avoir tout les trucs sur Facebook, alors que je sais que c'est juste Facebook,
qui notifie l'anniversaire.
Euh, olala, j'ai l'impression d'être Mr Smith dans Matrix, j'avais même pas fais gaffe à ça !
Je suis né le 22 novembre.
*Tousse* 1900...quelque chose
Je suis donc un scorpion, je suis pas sagittaire.
Flo: Salut Fabien, est ce que tu prévois de descendre sur Toulouse pour rencontrer tes abonnés autour d'un bon petit verre *accent*
Flo: Continue tes vidéos, elles sont super !
Merci ! C'est vraiment cool comme message.
Je vais revenir sur Toulouse pour jouer le spectacle donc on pourra se voir ouais, en même temps euh...
Surement après le spectacle ou ça dépend de combien de temps je reste
J'avais jouer au Zénith de Toulouse pour les printemps du rire, j'ai joué aussi au Rex de l'humour,
qu'est le théâtre des...qu'est le théâtre des chevaliers du fiel.
Donc je reviendrais à Toulouse avec le nouveau spectacle c'est sûre
et un bon petit verre *Avec accent toulousain*, comme tu as dis !
Dans la ville en rose ! *Accent*
Non, je n'utilise jamais mes connaissances à des fins personnelles.
Comme vous avez pu le constater dans les true story d'ailleurs.
Euh, écoute il y a rien de programmé pour l'instant en Italie.
J'ai déjà joué en Italie, par le biais de bateau de croisière avec Philippe Roche que vous avez déjà vu ici aussi.
Mais là, j'ai rien de prévue en Italie non.
Ah cool !
Et ben Manon, c'est cool que t'es pas eu de question,
mais que je saches que tu fais la traduction en Espagne des vidéos, c'est vraiment cool.
D'ailleurs, tu sais que si tu veux, tu peux sous titrer les vidéos en espagnole directement sur YouTube.
Comme ça, ça permet de les rendre accessibles aux Espagnoles.
Et j'en profite, comme je fais de temps en temps, pour remercier tous ceux d'entre vous qui sous titres les vidéos en Français,
pour quelle soit accessibles aux malentendants, merci beaucoup !
Merci à tous ceux qui font du sous-titrages, ça c'est vraiment énorme !
Je suis un peu déçu pour le bug, je pense que si on l'avait fait en live comme je voulais le faire au départ,
Je les aurais ouvert au fur et à mesure en fait !
Ça doit être aussi pour ça qu'à partir d'un certain délais, peut être on peut pas les ouvrir
Dites moi dans les commentaires si vous voulais qu'un de ces quatre, on se refasse une FAQ Snapchat
et que ce coup-ci on se le fasse en live directement.
Où j'ouvre en temps réel, je fais la vidéo en temps réel et vous les envoyez sur un créneau.
On se prévoit 2-3 heures comme ça et je les ouvre et je filme en continue.
On fera comme ça, ça sera mieux du coup.
Merci en tout cas à vous, d'avoir envoyé tous ces snaps, toutes ces questions.
J'espère que les réponses sont satisfaisantes, j'espère qu'elles vous plaisent.
N'oubliez pas le défi, que je me suis lancé, à 50 000 abonnés,
j'organiserai une soirée où je vais vous présenter des morceaux du nouveau spectacle
Euh, mais en mode comme ça informel en buvant un coup, qu'on puisse discuter de tout ça.
Ça sera une espèce de...de Mental Up
Ça sera un Meet Up mais où je ferais un peu de mentalisme aussi avec vous
Je vous donne tous les détails dans la vidéo n°100, là dessus.
Merci aussi de partager les vidéos, c'est ce qui ramène des nouvelles personnes dans la Mental Team.
Non, dans la Team Mentalo, parce que ça c'est notre nom, à nous, qui nous unis.
Et j'ai tapé dans le pied de caméra.
Prenez bien soin de vous, si vous voulez aussi qu'on fasse une FAQ,
une 2eme FAQ Snapchat mais en temps réel dites le moi dans les commentaires,
ou alors vous laissez simplement aussi un pouce en l'air, parce que un pouce en l'air ça fais plaisir.
Je vais vous faire un petit snap de fin, pour vous dire que c'est fini.
Ainsi s'achève la vidéo 140 sur les 366 de cette année.
Merci encore une fois pour tout, c'est un vrai kiff de vous faire ces vidéos.
Et rendez-vous demain à 17h pour le prochain Mental Vlog !
Ciao !